so boys and girls here's a little secret
for getting more presents for christmas
than you could ever imagine
ask for one from a politically correct
shopping mall santa and then film the
[Music]
response
[Music]
what do you think
[Music]
it's okay
[Music]
so just to be clear to the kids watching
at home that was not the real santa the
real santa got a cold and didn't want to
spread it to the kids
so santa trusted the shopping mall to
find a reasonable substitute
the problem was it was on short notice
and they ended up with this glum
fella who spreads christmas cheer the
way i spread sobriety
not well and so instead of santa claus
they got a santa cause
but sorry dude the little boy didn't ask
for an ak-47 he asked for
a toy nerf gun if you can't tell the
difference you deserve to get stuck in a
chimney
behind joy behar thank god you didn't
ask for a gi
joe the warmonger or a gas-guzzling hot
wheel
or maybe an elf on a shelf i tell you i
am not for sale
now here's the good news millions of
people have likely seen
seen this pc santa reduce the boy to
tears which means given that this is
america
the greatest most generous country on
earth you can bet that little tyke
got more nerf guns than the portland
police department has
who by the way are only allowed nerf
guns heck maybe the real santa
may pay him a visit true there was a
mistake made yesterday
well we're so sorry about that i heard
about this on the
north pole
there you go and as for social justice
santa
well that video went around the world
faster than donner or blitzen which
means all he's getting for christmas is
coal
also delivered by the real santa and
you'll know it's him because of the huge
carbon footprint
all right i i'm gonna say one thing in
defense of the sa
the shopping mall santa it might have
been a policy
could have been a policy of the mall who
knows uh no
it wouldn't have been a policy of the
mall and that mother had an
infant with her she had to put the
infant down to console the little boy in
the meantime if i had been a bystander i
would have taken a dive
across that desk and broken that fat ass
glasses
we don't know if he's actually fat don't
don't fat shame
uh hey jesse do i you know the other big
story about this
the enduring quality of nerf products
that we are still talking about nerf
products
we've had nerf products since we were
like four
yeah i mean i asked my parents for a
nerf gun for christmas and they said no
too
because they're far left and look how i
turned out
i'm a fox host mom i mean that backfired
didn't it
but i mean when i heard this i heard
your monologue which was a great
monologue when i heard this today
the first thing i did was look up how
much mall santas make
obviously and they make between 30 and
100 an hour so in december
they can clear 5 to 10 grand if i'm
getting paid 5 to 10 grand to sit there
that kid could ask for anthrax ho ho ho
whatever you want kiddo
anthrax i think that was a rejected
reindeer name
geraldo uh what do you make of this do
you think any sympathy for the poor
santa you know uh ever since the billy
bob thornton movie bad santa where we
played a drunken
uh reprobate uh santa i can't i can't
get into santa anymore i wouldn't let
any small
child related to me near uh jelly old
elf
and who knows what's in those those red
velvets i was a shopping mall santa i
was
i was at the king of pressure
yeah i was actually i was reprimanded
for drinking wine at lunchtime
dana you're you're you like you're more
like a smurf than a nerf
i think the shocking news here is is
that you were a santa not an
elf is that right how dare you
it's true